You don't flicky-Flonk my lights you bastard!
Eugh, I'm gonna get ya- *screams*
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome to seed.
Now this game is about you exploring an obscure
Remote location that was struck by earthquakes.
And holy crap its da- OHH kay
Ah. I love the retro graphic very Silent Hill esque. I don't know what's lurking in these woods behi- besides the slender man of course.
Hi?
Hello?
Someone playin' kick ball out there?
Ohhhh,
Ah ha.
That's good, an abandoned building covered in flies always fun. Oh
Sh*thole sweet sh*thole I was about to say the same thing yeah, I'll better walk inside and breathe deeply the fumes.
eh
This place is horrible,
Nyeh, I can't crouch oh no i'm stuck, ahh what a lovely bed, how many people have been in that bed
gross
So why am I out here, I'm not...- it didn't say anything about me being in like a journalist, oh these are graves well
Don't mean to disturb the dead, but here. I go towards the shovel with the distinct aim of disturbing the dead
Why is this sh*thole outside of the sh*thole covered in...
What I can only assume to be buttholes?
Welp, got a key...
hmmm,
Suspicious.
Suspiciousy spishish spoosh
Alright I'll take it.
Gotta, pull my flashlight out again,
*mumbles* I dont like that..
I don't like this at all.
I'll keep going but I gotta go through the sh*thole again, and I don't know why I needed to do that in the first plaehhh,
Ahh!
Is this the sh*thole door that I need to sh*thole?  ooh I have a key oh
How do I get my inventory?
*spook*
Ooh!
There we go, okay, we got it we're gonna go into the basement which is where I wanted to go
Why did I go into the baseme?- OOAH this is not a basement this is a hole in the ground...
I'd like to think I know the difference between a basement and a hole in the ground
But if you ask me what what the difference is I actually...
.. Is there a difference between a basement and a hole in the ground?
I have no idea
I think either way we can all agree that this is unfinished.
*weird moaning*
I'm sorry for criticizing your amazing basement here. I'll just keep meandering towards the danger
Oh boy, so who is uh? Who's moaning? I've got a lot of exp-
Experience with moaning. oh, that's a bony moany
oooh, I dont like that
what are you?
AH Its a Mannequin!
*reads* Corey Wilson's has been attached to some kind of puppet
usually that would be the indication that I need to f*ck off, when I see a
bathtub in the bottom of a hole in the ground with the skull and I mannequin body pretty sure
pretty sure I should get the fudge out of here Hey sir excuse me sir you all right. I'm gonna back away slowly
So I don't get chased by yooou
Well, it's awfully reassuring that there's some kind of thumpy thumpy heartbeat going on in there
So I'm gonna go I'm gonna go away now, and then I'm gonna turn around about half way up this hole
ooh
Sumthin' gonna happen...
I know it
My horror ss s s ssss sssenses are tingling. okay, Well we're gonna load there
*door slam noise*
Ah!
thump!
alright.. well...
Glad I left that all that behind me. Oh is it daytime? Oh am I blocked in here? Oh all good
d- developments
come to me... ah
Thank you. Yes. This is exactly what I wanted oh
Boy, oh boy.
Can I move the trash? I need to go up. Oh apparently I can nevermind hello
Ah good!
*rumble* Ayy!
what the
Sh*tty d*cks was that
Did I get some kind of disease?
Did I step on a needle seems like something that could have happened here
did I spray jam on my face?
what is this?
What is that sound?
*weird sounds*
nn.. I dont like that
*sword sound*
Whoa did I pull an axe out of the wall? I think I pulled an axe out o-okay? Well I guess we're done then...
It's just gonna crash? Oh, okay. Well apparently that's just the ending. That's not a crash
That's just it ending so I'm gonna -  I -
That was uh... too short, so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna play another game that may not be... all that high quality. I mean that game was fine
It was building somewhere, and I liked the UH I liked the ambience that he was doing
But now I'm gonna play a game called. "They come at poop time"
And I didn't know if I was gonna be able to play this-
But I uh... so glad that I did.
AH! Yes, there are four enemies: one in the sink; one in the window; one in each door. Sink Enemy: pops up every now and then,
With a noise. When he's visible press E while pointing at him, lights must be on.
Window Enemy: when he's inside the room, looking down at you, you have to turn the lights OFF before he gets you.
He will go away after a while.
You can slow him down by looking at him while he is outside. Left Door Enemy: Will occasionally knock on your door. You have to answer him
By pressing E on the door. Lights must be ON. doouh... Right Door Enemy:
He will appear in the mirror. When he's in the mirror, you can look at him and slow him down while he's in.
what the hell?!
well y- This is... this is basically uh... The Joy of Creation! (*giggles*)
That's what this is. Oh not while I'm pooping
oh no!
oh...
Jeez... okay, alright, wait...
Woah!
Okay well my poop is in-in-incoming so... that's nice.
I have no ide- HEY!!!!
WHAT THE F*CKING HELL WAS THAAAAT!?
WHY YOU DISTURBIN MY POOP TIME!?
DON'T DO THAT!
Oh hi. Okay well... Alright.
What do I do about you? I can turn the lights o- (SQUACK!!!), oh....
(*knock knock*) I'M TRYNA SHET EN 'ERE!
what do I do about that one...
i don't know! I don't know! i don't know!  i dont know!-..
hey, HEY!!! Get  the frick outa my sink.
What're you doing there?
What are you DOING!
I dunno
(*Farts...?*) AHHHHH!!!!
The light should probably..- EY! EY!!
STOP THAT!
I don't like- I'M TRYNA SHET EN 'ERE!!! (Mark Repeats) I'M TRYNA SH*T IN 'ERE!
WHAT ARE YOU DOING!? STAHHHHHP!!!
Oh sh*tty di*ks...
Ah sh*t... Sh*t bwah!
oh your gone oh... ok alright
oh *Click*
Ah doodly do...
Don't mind me. Tryna POOP.
just Poopin-...(*4 Knocks*)
STOP
(*CLICK*)
STOP. "Occupied!"
(*FART SQUACK*)
Well, was that a poopy sound?
Was that me successfully poopin? (*Growling*) Stop.
Just gotta poop in the dark
HEY! Oh sh*t, well that's not...
*Monstrous screaming*
HEYYYYYY!!!! MY LIGHTS!!!
You don't flicky flonk my lights you bastard!
oh I'm gonna....
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
NOOOOOOO!!!! I'm constipooted?!
*snickers*
(*giggles*)
heh it's so silly.
That's about the silliest thing I've ever seen and oddly enough pretty scary
That is weird. That is weird. I gotta admit. That is crazy
Huh that was better than I ever expected it to be. Are there different rules for every single...
(*Stunned*) Oh my god, there are...
Make them go away by throwing toilet paper at them!?
That's amazing!
Oh my god
It's so diverse. This game is
Amazing alright, so I'm gonna end this here
But do you guys want to see a full playthrough
of They Come at Poop Time? Cuz that game is amazing. Holy sh*. I mean honestly. Holy sh*t that game was amazing
Alright, anyway. Let me know if you want to see a full playthrough of
They Come at Poop Time because that was pretty [darn] good and let me know what you think of a seed
1.2 Demo down in the comments below as well.
And thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as always,
I will see you...
IN THE NEXT VIDEO!
BUH BYE!
*music*
please dont add extra side comments in the subtitles, its distracting.
- mark
*music*